[Music]
homie look what I become
okay so we had to do this because of all
the mess that's been going on you've
been asking about it pat we got to do a
podcast we got to do a podcast
and as crazy of a schedule as we're
having we decided to have it and we got
Barry Habib in the house he's got a lot
of numbers 47 slides we're not going to
go through all of them but we will go
through something all 40 seconds
he's got some uh jobs uh data that no
one's talking about some uh numbers on
uh uh uh rates I know today I saw the
report I'm sure we all saw the the
lowest in 26 days we'll talk about that
Tom uh you got a bunch of stuff going on
with Silicon Valley Bank everybody does
Adam all of us here uh with the news I
just did a uh what do you call it a um
uh Twitter spaces earlier with Mario on
Twitter everybody was on everyone's
commenting on what's going on with
Silicon Valley Bank it's been a scare
and today's market I put a question I
put a poll in the morning will today end
up the market being up or down
71 of the people that voted say the
Market's gonna be down only 29 percent
so the Market's going to be up you want
me to update you exactly on the market
what is going on in the market Rob if
you can pull it up to see how the market
is doing because the reality of it is
everything's in green today very weird
except except for the Russell 2000 no
except for banking banking individual
Banks everything else there we go isn't
a green today with the stock market so
having said that having said that I say
yeah uh we just get right into it with
the main topic that everybody is talking
about which is Silicon Valley Bank 16th
largest bank in America to uh uh uh go
uh fail the last time this happened was
I believe WAMU and I remember wama was a
roughly 330 billion dollar company that
chase ended up buying for 1.9 billion if
you want to zoom this in so we can take
a look at this uh Zoom it in so people
can see exactly the chart uh Rob if
you're doing it that way we can't see it
by the way when did we have the former
CEO of one yeah we had a mom we had him
on a few months ago that was a few and
that was what talk about timing yeah
you've you've gone on and on about what
happened with WAMU and how disappointed
it was you real you remember what
happened afterwards in the interview how
upset his wife was and how upset him I
look listen his wife was not happy this
is what you did this you were the CEO
this is why we're asking you right there
is WAMU if you look at the chart on the
left
and the one on the right if you can zoom
in again Rob what you just did is fine
no no do what you did just go to the
green
yeah if you can okay
oh Rob we are way off today buddy you're
normally good but today we're Rob
slacking okay it's all good let me get
right into so the 16 largest bank in
America goes bankrupt the last time this
happened fails the last time this
happens was 330 Billion Auto Company
chase ends up buying for 1.9 billion
dollars here's an article from uh uh uh
you have the charts you're showing okay
so Silicon Valley Bank collapses and
second biggest U.S bank failure ever
this is an independent story
california-based Silicon Valley Bank was
seized by Regulators on Friday making it
the second biggest bank failure in U.S
history since 2008 collapsed Obama which
had 307 billion dollars in asset when it
was shuttered on 25th of September 2008
10 days after Lehman Brothers failed
Silicon Valley Bank failed after
depositors mostly technology workers and
Venture Capital bad companies started
withdrawing their money creating a run
on the bank the bank had approximately
209 billion dollars in total assets and
about 175 billion dollars in total
deposits as of 31st December of 2022
this is Silicon Valley Bank
and it was unclear how many of its
deposits were above 250 000 in short
limit guaranteed by FDIC
93 right there uh however there is a
little chance of contagion in the
banking sector at Major Banks of
sufficient Capital to avoid a similar
situation so this has scared a lot of
people uh I'll go to you first uh Barry
based on what we know what was your
reaction were your surprise and then
we'll get into how we feel about the way
they're handling it whether it's yelling
Biden because he gave a speech today so
okay there's a lot to unpack here so
I'll just try and be quick here so so
this bank had problems because
in 2008 under the Dodd-Frank they were
allowed to invest in assets that wasn't
a bad decision necessarily to invest in
these assets but what happened was that
they were yielding on 82 billion dollars
worth of Investments around 2 percent
now it's okay because if you're paying
your depositors very little you could
make some spread there but as you know
when somebody deposits money in your
bank you don't have all those assets on
hand you keep roughly 10 percent the
rest you lend out to try and make the
Arbitrage to try and make the spread
that's how Banks make money the problem
is is that a lot of these Investments
were now underwater you see when you
invest in a lot of the bonds that they
invested in they invested in
mortgage-backed security so a three
percent mortgage equals a two percent
coupon because everybody takes a piece
of the two percent coupons I'm getting
two percent that's okay if I'm paying a
half of one percent I'm making money on
it okay however what starts to happen is
as the FED has maniacally raised rates
without thinking about the consequences
they're not very in unintended
consequences they now give people
alternatives to move their money so now
you can move your money to a short-term
six-month uh Treasury and get five
percent so people start withdrawing
money tech companies were doing a little
bit more poorly as we know they start
having less Capital there's less money
going in so what happens is that the
bank now has to make up this money where
do they get it from they have to now
sell assets here's the real craziness of
it
they had on their books 12 billion
dollars positive but it really wasn't
because once you started looking deep
what they had was invested in these
bonds that were now underwater under
Dodd-Frank these are considered now to
be no risk assets so you do not have to
report under Dodd-Frank unrealized
losses they had 15 billion in unrealized
losses this was not a solvent Bank there
were three billion unsolvent as at the
end of last year which is why the CEO
was selling stock which is why you had
insiders getting paid bonuses up front
and early now the they start to get
exposed because Jim Cramer an amazing
five weeks ago touts this as this as the
stock you got to buy okay it is out Jim
Cramer was out there look at this thing
again February I swear I got we got the
video is this the same Jim Cramer that
compared uh Sam begman freed to
Rockefeller Andrew Carnegie there's
actually an ETF which is a contrary Jim
Cramer but anyway really on point here
let me get to just so you know so Jim
Cramer on February 8th talks about how
the Stock's undervalued how it has room
to run it's his quote it was at three
hundred and twenty dollars there's watch
this just watch watch this put the audio
so we can hear it
it's the Jim Cramer dead cat watch this
here today this svb financial don't you
want this company is a merchant bank
with a deposit base That Wall Street
have been stately concerned about SUVs
recently bought one of our favorite
research firms Buffett Nathanson it's
become less dependent upon private
equity and venture capitalist offerings
wait a second let's try to play sure
they could come back yeah some of them
come back here with a stock directly
affectionate oversold position stock was
the fourth worst performer in 2022. I
think the fears were not justified it's
a very compelling situation hey by the
way long-term private Equity Venture
Capital let them go on a way being the
banker to these best invents pools of
capital has always been a very good
business Stock's still cheap now you
have to remember that a stock that's
just a few weeks ago percent like
February 8th yeah five weeks it takes it
a lot more to cover if you're losing
two-thirds of your value you need a 200
gain to get back to even this is
arithmetic some people call it geometry
so you could argue svb's nearly 40 Value
this year is barely a drop in the bucket
and that's how I want you to think it
that's crazy I think it's a good example
of why these bounce back moves might be
far from over these stocks could have
more room to run especially if you think
they were driven down to artificially
low levels that's crazy
impossible but but you should find the
chart on this but but here this is a
classic this is svb It's a classic dead
cat bounce but he's right but here's why
this is significant yeah because this
draws attention to svb now whether you
want to think of it as investment or not
now people start digging in and as
people dig in what do they see they see
this 15 billion in unrealized losses
that they didn't have to report but now
they you dig in and what do they start
telling their clients they start telling
your clients hey you know what this bank
is vulnerable I'd probably take my money
out of there and as deposits start now
cascading out of there
this is where they have to raise money
they go to raise 21 billion and they do
because they have to but how do they do
it they sell some of their Assets Now
when you sell those 21 billion they
Cherry Picked them only 2 billion in
losses but now you have to realize those
losses right so when people look under
the hood they say there's another 13
billion in unrealized losses people
start pulling out money in droves they
can't make they can't borrow money the
shorts are attacking the stock they
can't issue stock and this is how it
happens so quickly so so let me let me
let me just give some of the stats if
you can show uh have this year 16th
largest bank 97 of the money at Silicon
Valley Bank is not protected by FDIC
I've seen 93 I've seen 97 whoever's
right one of the two either way it's a
lot of money 12 days ago like 13 days
ago the CEO Gregory Becker sold 11 of
his shares Daniel Beck the CFO sold 32
percent of his Holdings CMO Michelle
Draper sold 28 of her Holdings around
5.1 million dollars if you if you put
the picture of Forbes just seven days
ago this one right here by the way they
took the Tweet down just so you know
that's the one I posted but yeah they
took it down it just it just go to the
picture I sent you it's another one of
those pictures I sent you rob that
should be on your phone uh go one more
go one more right there look at this
this is their tweet this is six days ago
proud to be on Forbes annual ranking of
America's best banks for the fifth
straight year and to also have been
named the publication inaugural
Financial All-Stars list they tweeted
this I retweeted this they took it down
because they obviously you know I'm sure
a lot of people were retwing this this
was all over the place they don't want
people to see just five five days ago
you're bragging about this so this
becomes the question there's a
terminology called front running right
you know what Front Runners if you can
pull up the definition of front running
front running uh let's just read the
exact definition the practice by market
makers of dealing on Advanced
information provided by their Brokers
and investment analysis before their
clients have been given the information
okay this is is if an investor does this
What's worst is when you're in it you're
the guy that knows what's about to
happen and you do it isn't this a crime
time to do something like this I'm on
that page I'd like to see an
investigation I'll tell you why I am
right here with with Barry Butler great
to see you today good to see you brother
is
on March 1st Becker was at an event in
Los Angeles and he said we pride
ourselves on being the best financial
partner in the most challenging times he
said that but he said that and then was
heading to London where he was going to
go get a Bank Of The Year honor at this
London deal on the second it gets better
he had already been told that there was
a call coming from Moody's Moody's had
looked at a footnote that was in there
because remember they don't have to
disclose everything in standard post
page that they had the 15 billion
dollars Moody saw that and came back and
said hey we have a question are you if
you were to look at this as a mark to
Market rather than a mark to maturity
where are you at here because our
assessment is we're going to lower you
two ratings levels Pat two and he said
what do we have to do you have to clean
this up and part of the plan to clean it
up exactly as Barry just said sell 20
billion of it but technically that's
depositor money that was the positive
money you put in the bonds now you have
to sell the bonds are short and then you
have to cover the hole it's called well
how do you cover the hole tell you what
we'll call some of our favorite Venture
capitalists and we'll issue some stock
even though they were already down from
7.25 to 325 down 400 points in the
preceding 12 months and they're going to
dilute that kind of a down and so they
went out to dilute it but now we all
know what happened the bank runs started
General Atlantic I think was the VC that
backed out on the half a billion dollars
they were getting it they were getting
advice from Goldman Sachs which was
really bad advice the whole way down and
in fact the management had changed they
became very very smug it used to be a
great bank but then they were like we're
you know they thought they were too good
for themselves they didn't try to endear
themselves to any potential investors
eventual capitalists they were like they
were not friendly to the environment so
they nobody wanted to invest with them
but to Pat's point about front running
you freaking know that you have
footnoted your earnings report Pat he
knew he footnoted it and he knew that
Moody's was in the lobby saying we got
to talk and we may take you down two
ratings levels and yet he did this I'm
with Pat I think there should be a
deeper investigation on This this term
front running I've never heard this term
but we've all heard the term insider
trading and I I Googled oh no versus
insider trading and it's actually the
same thing it says front running is
similar
to insider trading with the minor
difference in this case that the broker
works for the client's brokerage rather
than the inside the client's business so
it's a form of insider trading is what
Front Runners but this is this is this
is even worse though like what Nancy
Pelosi and her husband get you know
accused of is insider trading what a lot
of these Congress people how are you
worth 140 million dollars on 160 000
salary okay that could be worth uh
insider trading dude you're on the
inside you know exactly what's going on
the level of audacity to go up there and
collect it and then come back and say
hey we got the bank of the Year hey guys
sell off because this is 13 billion
let's do it quickly look what's gonna
happen over and then and then now it's
leading into what we are today and by
the way when you look at their
backgrounds of what they did just kind
of want to give you a background of what
they did the CEO was a director at San
Francisco fed the CFO was a former
Analyst at Freddie Mac the chief
administrative officer which you guys
were kind of putting up he was a former
CFO of Lehman Brothers the chief risk
officer LED credit ratings in 2007 the
chief legal officer was General Counsel
at Citibank in 2008 so to say they have
a star-studded lineup of people with
experience to make sure a company
doesn't make the mistake that Lehman
Brothers made or others made they have
it and they still did this before we go
into the question that I want you to
give your feedback on you know I want to
talk about what the 250 000 is enough
whether we need to increase that I want
to talk about a few things on the inside
that I got an email from Goldman this
morning I'm going to share with you guys
I want to talk about Dodd-Frank a video
from Trump that's circulating about what
he said in 2018 and a lot of people are
blaming Trump for this Midas Touch and a
lot of these guys which we'll talk about
that let me first go to our sponsors
today's sponsors Masterworks uh if you
guys have been following the content you
know at this point I've spoken about
these guys quite a lot I'm a guy that
likes collectible carts I like
non-duplicatable assets and the more
people I spend time with who have money
they make a lot of their investment into
art as an alternative form of investment
that's getting a good way to return the
challenges Tom and Barry a lot of times
when you make those types of Investments
people don't have the money to buy five
million dollar piece of art or a 10
million dollar Bank seat or Warhol or
whatever maybe but what Masterworks does
is allows you to buy shares of a piece
of art this just gives you an example of
what some of their pieces have done uh
in a rate of return net rate of return
this is on their side by the way
everything is uh uh approved by the SEC
if you go in there you can read their
report you can see what they've done
which which ones are qualified with the
SEC and broken into shares so for me if
this is an area you want to get into
nearly 600 000 members are already
taking advantage of Masterworks if you
want to be on the list and get through
it you can use our access to have access
to it with what their doing paintings
are selling out fairly quickly what
they're doing something for you to
consider especially with all the mess
that's going on right now whether it's
art collectible carts things that are
non-duplicatable especially being
verified but people that do that work
for you not you buying art and you don't
know if it's real or not they do all
that stuff for you up front you don't
have to worry about it look up
Masterworks we're going to put the link
below uh Rob for them to be able to take
advantage of it it'll be in the
description and the chat so going back
at it so uh Barry you see the list of
all these names of people qualified
their background director of San
Francisco fit former Analyst at
Frederick former CFO of Lehman Brothers
Brothers let credit ratings in 2007
which is the chief risk officer or
former general counsel at Citibank in
2008 what are you thinking about them
knowing if you had all this experience
couldn't you have prevented this from
happening yeah here's a couple of things
so number one they did not have a chief
risk officer from April 29th till
January 4th Tom am I right on that
that's exactly right okay consecutive
months eight consecutive month so they
did not have a chip why did you not
replace your Chief are you risk it
officer they did not and by the way
lauraetta stepped down from her role as
cro in April of 22. yeah so now you
don't have a cheese brisk you pull that
up but wait a second what's happening at
the same time at the same time your risk
is increased dramatically because the
FED has now gone on a rampage raising
rates
until something breaks and here
something is breaking so during that
time if you take a look from the four
and a half months from June 15th the FED
raised rates 300 basis points in a seven
and a half month period they raised at
375 basis points and in the last year
they've raised 450 basis points you need
a chief risk officer to what this is a
mismatch in duration short-term rates
are going up and my long-term
Investments are going down in value I
need a chief risk officer to de-leverage
that not after they've gone up 450 basis
points on the short end but after maybe
the first 75 basis points and after
long-term rates start coming up start
unlevering these things start putting
hedges in place this is what you're
supposed to be doing to protect the
assets of the bank yeah it's while
you're shown this year Laura stepped
down from the role as a CRS SVP Bank
April 2022 uh what in what paper is this
what magazine is this Forbes and
formerly Department company in October
according to an SVP proxy filing the
bank appointed a permanent by the way
here's what's weird it if you run a
broker dealer you can't run a broker
dealer without an osj office of
supervisory you can't have it without a
branch office manager or boss's
depending on the size of it how the hell
is a company this size able to even
operate with Tom that's very confusing
to me how somebody can operate without a
cro it is we came from insurance for
people that are listening and we had uh
Patrick had put even though we were a
fmo very large Nationwide fmo Pat
included in the management team a chief
compliance officer which he wasn't
required to do but all the carriers had
that because we always wanted to be one
step better and look one step cleaner
and in this case by the way supposedly
Pat she didn't leave in October that's
just her last day of pay she left in
April and then there was like this
period of time where she got her salary
and benefits but she wasn't in the
building so so what is the I wonder what
the level of responsibility is to
disclose this to investors
and account holders to know we don't
have a cro in payroll right now is there
any disclosure that you have to disclose
and let them know it is do they have
that kind of responsibility or you don't
know the answer to the regulations and
if it was these these these folks
probably footnote number 82 along with
the 15 billion so so you know what this
takes me if you were going to say
something I just said I got a bunch of
other questions there's so many moving
Parts here and every day it's we're
learning more information but from your
guys uh Optics is this is this fraud is
this idiocy is this a lack of leadership
clearly there these guys are all Smart
Guys they've been around the banking
industry forever what does this boil
down to
you know it's very hard to say and
without the benefit of knowing what
happened behind closed doors you know
you can only assume things right but it
sure doesn't seem like this was run
correctly you know you have to see these
Fed rate hikes coming you see the
mismatch in duration somebody needed to
step up and say we have to make some
adjustments or changes while there might
be short-term pain we can't let this get
out of control gotcha and let me ask you
one more question because you kind of
threw it in there initially and my
antennas went up because you use the
word that we all you learned in 2008 MBS
mortgage-backed Securities you said that
earlier and I was like holy [__] we're
going there again no no what's that
these These are performing loans there
was no problem with delinquencies this
is just an interest rate move so if
somebody's back think about how many
three percent mortgages there were right
so the coupons that they fall into is a
two percent coupon in other words a
borrower pays three percent but by the
time the originator servicer securitize
everybody Fannie and Freddie makes a
piece there's two percent left in the
coupon for an investor like us right or
if you're a bank and you put a lot of
your assets in they're getting a return
to two percent I think their average uh
return was like 1.86 let's call it two
percent is what they're getting so if
they're getting two percent on that
think about this you're receiving two on
elongated maturity you get that's the
rate you're getting but as the open
market gets to three and four and five
on the coupon where it is now is it five
on the coupon
who's going to buy your two percent
coupon they will if you discount it
enough to make things balance out so at
a discount they'll buy it but meanwhile
that's the 15 billion dollars that they
had in losses so it wasn't always 15
billion as rates are going up maybe it
was 1 billion maybe it was 2 billion
that's the time where you could put
Hedges you could put puts you can
unleverage some of that that's what the
chief risk officer should have been
doing and they've been living for so
long under zurp right zero interest rate
you know policy and
to buy for a bank for a bank think about
it on the balance sheet they were
holding it as marked to maturity no Bank
can buy a bond and Market to maturity
because when it's when they're using
deposits it's part of the deposits by
definition the deposits in a real tough
economic situation have to be liquid
enough to to be retrieved so how do you
buy a bond marked to maturity when you
and say Barry and I have a bunch of real
estate and we buy a bond Mark to
maturity and you guys and you say you
guys are idiots you got it at two
percent we're saying we're just holding
it to the end we don't have to sell it
so we're only going to make two percent
but that's okay it's just going to pay
out right and then we're going to get
the principal back but if that was a
situation where we needed it to be
liquid then we get screwed and what was
the screw the screw was 20 billion sold
1.8 billion loss that was what they had
to pay off to the buyer to get them to
take it off there but the held to
maturity was allowed legally to be done
by the Dodd-Frank regulation which says
it does not come off of tier one Capital
so these are deemed to be held to mature
in other words okay the market
fluctuation we just talked about guys if
theoretically you held it until it got
paid off or till it matured you get 100
you get par value back so there's no
theoretical loss but if you wanted to
Market like you said to the actual
market value there's a significant
amount of loss in where it is so what
the FED did by setting up this facility
is they said okay we will lend against
what you have so what happens is they
say we'll take it based upon the par
rate we will not give you a haircut but
now you got to pay us you got to pay us
you know four and three quarters five
percent today's rate today's rate you're
getting two percent back but it's going
to eat into your profit margin the other
thing Patrick you said before which is
very interesting and obviously this is
where we're going is now at the present
time all deposits are insured not just
the 250. think about a small Regional
Bank that today has to pay and they
can't maybe can't afford it that much to
pay that FDI Insurance FDIC Insurance on
all their deposits what that may do is
that guys that may force a lot of
concentration these small Banks help
startup companies they help you they're
your local bank right that's who you
have the relationship I mean it could be
where we see it like a utility where
they're all just concentrated and run by
the government
so here here becomes a question which is
kind of Adam I think what you were what
you were asking responsibility goes on
who if you if you think about this
conversation we're having on the on the
spaces was okay whose fault is this you
know because right now they're calling
it a they're not calling to their
bailout they're calling to what uh it's
just a backstopper and by the way
bondholders are probably screwed
shareholders are probably screwed we're
protecting the people that deposit it
but it's not a bailout you know but
she's not he's not a snitch you know
so yeah it's a balance it's a balance
look what Yellen says here on page three
uh Yellen says no bailout for Silicon
Valley Bank we're not going to do that
again treasury sector and secretary
Yellen started uh stated that the
federal government will not provide a
bailout to Silicon Valley Bank but we'll
work to meet the needs of depositors who
stand to lose Millions after the bank
collapsed last week Yellen signaled that
government bailouts like those from 2008
crime financial crisis would not be
considered but The Regulators would wait
a wide range of available options for
protecting depositors who had more than
FDIC amount of 250 000 in their accounts
yell and try to assure or reassure
Americans that Silicon Valley Bank
collapse would not create a domino
effect for other Banks and that the core
problem Silicon Valley was Rising
interest rates rather than problems with
the tech sector okay so in a way when
you when you read this they're saying
it's not a Billet where does this money
come from is this money you know money
that's coming that taxpayers are not
going to be paying what are they going
to do just print it who pays the price
for that so here's here's the you know
when you um you crash your car Pat and
you have to tell your dad about it and
you're very careful about how you word
what what was going on when you're
wrecked that's what's going on here
she's saying it's not a bailout meaning
we're not printing money and we are not
taking money out of Treasury to pay for
this therefore it's not a bailout that's
what she's clinging to and I think
they're full of crap here's what they're
taking this out of what's called there's
a hundred billion dollar exchange
stabilization fund that's to stabilize
on emergency basis the mark markets wait
a minute wait a minute where did that
100 billion dollars come from Once Upon
a Time it came from treasury Once Upon a
Time it came from taxes Once Upon a Time
so she's saying we're not going to make
new printed money and new
um instant Appropriations on the
Congressional budget that's what she's
saying so this 100 million dollar
exchange stabilization fund she's taking
25 billion out of it and putting it
there along with this brand new other
device the
btfp bank term financing program where
they can now pay the difference between
FDIC and the deposit in the event of a
bank failure so guess what now a bank
can be irresponsible and say well we're
not going to get sued by the depositors
because the federal government's going
to back them up out of this thing and
it'll just be our shareholders and
bondholders that get screwed so I I
agree with I agree with Tom 100 I just
want to point out a couple of things on
Yellen so Friday she said the banking
sector is resilient that's almost like a
Baghdad Bob comment kind of like you
know there's nothing going on here right
nothing to see here guys because we make
sure it's resilient right and
inflation's just transitory transitory
here so then what happens is on Sunday
morning she says there's no shot of a
bailout I guess somebody must have
pulled her over on the side and said
hold on Janet this is much bigger than
you ever imagined because now people
can't make payroll that's what people
are freaking out and how am I going to
make payroll if the money's no good
right so because you could have two
three million in payroll it's not
uncommon for a lot of these companies so
now when we talk about bailout
what they are doing truly is a bailout
and here's why if I have something
that's worth a hundred dollars and I'm
getting paid by the government 130 way
above market and they say yeah it's okay
for me to pay you 130 because 10 years
from now you'll get the 130 back they're
theoretically not taking a loss but
they're holding it to maturity and they
get it back that's why they're claiming
it's not a ballot but they're paying
above market for it so therefore it's it
is there's no other way to look at it
other than it is a bailout they're
paying above market for something should
be worth let me ask you guys what you
know this whole reassurance and calming
don't you think it's sort of important
to define and explain what a bank run is
because that's essentially what this
comes down to no like you start to hear
these terms it's a banker and they're
trying to avoid a bank run and that's
just what that's the definition right
there I think Bank runs two discussions
let them read it go ahead Bank runs
happen when customers panic and everyone
tries to get their money out all at once
um the author explains that what
happened at Silicon Valley Bank leading
to the second biggest bank failure in
U.S history is essentially what happened
did you see the lines of people outside
getting their money like literally
yes I have well isn't it true that 90
plus of Silicon Valley Banks assets were
above the 250 000 FDIC insured meaning
it was all major money from Tech
startups millions and millions of
dollars in there so isn't it sorted on
the bank to diversify who it's getting
its money from I mean I don't know how
that it's not on the bank no no it's not
on the bank no this is not this okay so
who so if you look at this here this
this is this is this is how I process
this Rob if you want to stop because
you're distracting everybody just just
yeah we we're fine we don't need to see
the video so if you think about this
here's what I want you to think about so
in a situation like this Bill Ackman
comes out and says what it's not fair
this is not good we should build we
should you should figure out a way to
take care of the depositors and all this
other stuff and then David Sachs goes
and agrees with them and Vivek ramaswani
who was running for office comes out and
says no this is a bailout what are we
doing and then you know David calls him
out as a fox you know it's a very
interesting back and forth between sax
Ackman Vivek ramaswani and a lot of
other people right okay all heavyweights
oh no no it's fine it's all heavy
weights but now here becomes the thing
to be thinking about so when Benghazi
happened do you remember when Benghazi
happened how many people were killed
during Benghazi how many lives four four
people right and and if you're an
average person if you were a Democrat
you said what so Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton did their best I mean
what else do you expect them to do they
didn't do anything wrong they tried so
hard they had sleepless nights trying to
take care of this if you were Republican
what did you say Hillary Clinton this is
why she's this she was sleeping and she
didn't even want her to get up and see
what's going on and that picture they
posted with Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
and all this stuff that's just a picture
for media they posted right okay great
and then the average person three six 12
months later after the after what he
called the election debates were done
guess what they're going to the next
yeah new cycle hey what's the next thing
I'll say okay and people forgot about
Benghazi guess who's never forgot about
Benghazi till today the four families
the four families that lost somebody
fathers brothers mothers sisters
husbands you know wives and all this
stuff that in this case you're never
gonna forget this so think about those
four families if you're related in one
of those individuals was your son or
your brother or your father what do you
think you're gonna do the rest of your
life there may be Vengeance in you you
may have a feeling of what Revenge
you're never going to be the same if
your kid is going to say I'm gonna go to
the military your reaction is going to
be more dramatic than an average person
because you're experiencing that pain
your hate towards a Hillary Clinton or a
Barack Obama is going to be what higher
than anybody else because it's your
fault it happened under your watch can
you blame those four families no we
can't blame those for families however
let's bring it to the situation today
so
um s Silicon Valley Bank
they go through what they're going
through fine
who do you think cares about that
bailout the most people that have money
with Silicon Valley Bank who else you
think cares more the most those who have
their employees that they're paying the
salaries through Silicon Valley Bank who
else people who work for Silicon Valley
Bank they should care the most okay all
right secondly if you go to the people
who criticize capitalism the most which
capitalists do they criticize those
socialist Or democrats or low and middle
income families that say capital is all
they care about is what money and all
this other stuff who do they criticize
this is exactly what they criticize
because when you think about the the
foundation of capitalism there's four
things the foundation of capitalism
comes down to four things it's freedom
to buy it's freedom to try it's freedom
to sell you know what the last one is
it's the freedom to fail
a lot of people at this level want the
first three freedoms but they don't want
the fort Freedom what's the fort Freedom
dude you failed is what you did so what
do you want to do well we got to get our
money and all this other stuff okay fine
now some people say well you can't say
that if it was your money you would also
be saying the same thing to get the
money I'm not disputing that you're
right if I had money in there I would be
very concerned because that's my
family's money and rightfully so just
like you if you're 72 years old you're
probably less thinking about what it is
to be a barrier of Entry or regulation
holding people back from competing with
these super centers at Walmart or Target
or a financial code you're probably more
thinking about what Medicare Mets up
retirement you know Social Security and
you should because that's what's
affecting you directly right so I'm not
judging the people that have money in
Silicon Valley Bank but it is a right
criticism to say you want to be
protected but you go take all the risk
so what does this teach so imagine in
life how you create resentment for kids
I got four kids
if I discipline my oldest son more than
in a different way than I discipline my
youngest son I officially create
resentment between them two and from my
oldest to me if I discipline Tico for he
does something and I take iPad away from
him for two months but the same thing
Dylan does and I let him play iPad for
two months Tico's gonna say I knew he
was your favorite I knew he was your
favorite and today the low and middle
income families guess what they're
saying I knew they were your favorite
favorites fed I knew they were your
favors you bail them out again you gave
them money again you they're right you
sit there and try to say about this
argument but this does affect them
though Patrick because the payroll and
then the contagion to other Banks you
know I think the banking system the the
shareholders who invest in the banks
they're not being taken care of they're
going to probably lose everything the
the
people who loan money or the bondholders
they're probably going to get a fraction
of what they invested maybe I don't know
I don't know what it's going to be right
is anybody's guess as good of mine bonds
are first position they'll probably get
scraps but but then the depositors
that's that's the the everyday person
you know it's their money and if it
wasn't then the Valley Bank is not an
everyday person's bank I know but but
this is not a community bank but if it
would if it's not a this is a regional
bank there's only 27 Regional banks in
America but they're one of 27. but if
you worked for me you couldn't get paid
because your payroll was in there well
guess what happens there here's what I
would say what happens with there
there's a guy named Jamie Diamond okay
you know what Jamie Diamond did last
Thursday with his Bankers hey guys call
every single one we're doing an
all-nighter today call every single one
of the accounts and businesses that are
with Silicon Valley Bank tell them to
come over here here's what we're going
to do for you we'll take care of you
we're going to make sure your employees
get paid we're going to do this we're
gonna do that capitalism Works its way
out let me read you this this note that
the CEO of Shopify said now can you show
the CEO Shopify if you can read I'm
going to read this message to you right
there check this out go back one the
other way there you go zoom in hello
this is Kaz Shopify coo reaching out I
know that we've already sent you an
email your Shopify payments payout uh
going out to svb and asking you to
change your account on file please do
that I'm reaching out to also offer
something else if your funds are locked
up and you have trouble hitting payroll
please let me know we'll immediately
open up a balance account for you and
fund it with the amount of money your
payroll so you can pay your people don't
worry about signing anything now we'll
get lawyers to get paper things later we
won't charge you interest we'll let we
want to help you pay us back with no
interest when you're this is capitalism
so this is what I mean by a Jamie
Diamond season says okay svb Bank you
want to be irresponsible and Reckless
you want to get an award and then come
back there is a reason why this morning
can you pull up the one with the the
again email this morning from Goldman
first thing in the morning and I'm like
uh uh uh what's this email all about
that one right there zoom in look at
this they rate uh Banks the gsib uh you
have to know what gsib stands for gsib
stands for Global uh systematic
something here let me report important
Banks important Banks that's exactly
what gsibly it's a cousin deceive or
whatever yeah it's called globally
systematically important Banks what a
weak name but that's what they call it
go down a little bit so everybody can
seize it so at the top all the way at
the top meaning zoom in a little bit and
then we'll go from the top there you go
uh yeah there you go so the the most
stable bank they have JPMorgan Chase in
A League of Their Own by the way what's
empty above JP Morgan's why is that
meaning somebody hasn't reached the
level of three and a half percent which
is like the highest level is what
they're saying nobody's in a plus well
JPMorgan Chase is an A plus they just
don't have anybody that has a perfect
score so JP Morgan Chase at the top then
it's B of A Citigroup HSBC which HSBC
bought the UK branch of uh Silicon
Valley bank and then you have the next
year's Bank of China Barclays BMP
Deutsche Bank Goldman's Goldman Sachs
and then the next one you have Wells
Fargo is on that list by the way all the
way at the bottom so think about that
Wells is not at the B of A level Wells
is not at the chase level Wells is not
that the C City level a lot of attempts
people think who else is one of those
it's not Morgan's Stanley on a lower
list and then ing you see some of these
other guys right you see Wells by the
way down they're all the way at the
bottom you'll see them all the way right
there so so this kind of gets you to say
all right we got to be careful but this
is my concern and I want to ask the two
of you guys here on what you say with
this so when you when you look at
Dodd-Frank the video can you pull up the
video of trump with Midas Touch and uh
they share this and there's a whole
Community right now people that are
saying well you would never show this on
the podcast there's no way you're going
to talk about this on the podcast no we
kind of like to see both sides of the
argument this argument is this this
whole situation with Silicon Valley Bank
is Trump's fault if you can play this
clip the legislation I'm signing today
rolls back the crippling Dodd-Frank
regulations that are crushing Community
Banks
and Credit Unions Nationwide they were
in such trouble
one size fits all
those rules just don't work and
Community Banks and Credit Unions should
be
regulated the same way and you have to
really look at this they should be
regulated the same way
with Proviso for safety as in the past
when they were vibrant and strong but
they shouldn't be regulated
the same way as the large complex
financial institutions and that's what
happened and they were being put out of
business one by one
and they weren't Lending
since its passage in 2010 Dodd-Frank has
dealt a huge blow
to community banking
as a candidate I pledge that we would
rescue these Community Banks from
Dodd-Frank
the disaster of Dodd-Frank and now we
are keeping that commitment and all of
the people with me are keeping
that commitment we passed and signed a
record number of bills terminal you can
stop you at this point so so when you
see this you're understanding if you if
either one of you guys Barry or Tom what
was the cause of Dodd-Frank we know what
happened under Obama Barack Obama what
was the cause of Dodd-Frank and at the
same time What credibility do you give
to what Midas Touch and some of these
guys are talking about saying if Trump
wouldn't have deregulated some of these
regulations in Dodd-Frank this would
have never happened with Silicon Valley
Bank it wasn't because the loans were
not performing it wasn't because of bad
investment it was a duration mismatch it
happened because the FED went about a
course to raise rates in an
unsustainable manner without thinking
about unintended consequences if these
would have been
Investments that were turning up bad
that's one thing and then you could say
okay the fact that what was done here
and I believe that it isn't spoken about
in this clip but I believe what they're
discussing here is when he rolled back
the reserve requirement of how much
you'd have to keep for a small Bank
where it was it was removed that's that
the reserve requirement said that those
Banks could invest that money and wind
up making more profitability which had
which gave them options It Made for More
competition so I'm not saying right or
wrong I'm just trying to outline it
because I don't think that that really
displays what what the what the ruling
was that he removed so if if these were
bad loans that went bad well then you
could could go back to this clip and
said you know what if you would have had
more stranger rules and they made less
Investments maybe they would have been
smarter Investments okay but the
Investments were good
it just was a duration mismatch that
wasn't managed Tom what would you say
about that I I do two things first of
all the game when you have a weak leader
in the White House is to blame
predecessor so trains are getting
derailed oh Trump changed a ruling on
one type of cargo yet he's responsible
for all trains derailing now this
happens here oh this would have happened
wait a minute why haven't we had five or
ten Banks if Trump created a situation
where the banks could run willy-nilly
why do we only have one bad actor why
and that bad actor Dodd-Frank reserve
requirement forced to take Capital if
you're insolvent no exotic instruments
transparency and Reporting none of that
is present here in what happened with
Silicon Valley Bank these boneheads took
20 billion dollars put it into bonds
risk officer leaves nobody's paying
attention to the portfolio and then they
end upside down in remember seven less
than seven months
Jay Powell moves the rates and they're
upside down so do they sell it in the
Panic right that no they hung on to it
see and guess what he raised them again
and then it got worse so I don't see
anything under Dodd-Frank and I'd love
to see a tear down that says okay what
specific red light did svb run that was
not present in Dodd-Frank light after
Trump's move by the way I agree with you
the question yeah but but also Tom let's
remember within Dodd-Frank it gave svb
the ability to use hold to maturity and
not take the haircut right there they
were able to declare that it was the
total value that's what the problem was
in a lesson nobody learned
if anybody has watched The Big Short you
know that Mark to Market hiding in the
background is ultimately what kills big
stacks and this is this was what exactly
what Dodd-Frank allowed SBB to do so
dot-frank allowed for this yes it did
not the other way around exactly right
because Dot Frank allowed for the
provision that you now that 15 billion
lost you don't have to take it as a loss
you could say we're going to hold it to
maturity even though the market value
like Tom was saying they didn't have to
mark that to Market it doesn't come off
your tier one Capital as long as it's in
one of the assets that's deemed no risk
like an agency a balance sheet footnote
by and by the way by law that's all they
had to do Rob Rob just found this if we
can take a look at this in 2018 the
house passed a rollback of regulations
in Dodd-Frank by a vote of 258 to 150
not even close and in the Senate 17
Democrats joined Republicans so this is
both Democrats and Republicans joining
together to get the bill to Trump's desk
and sign into law which raised the bill
raise the threshold for regulation
standards from 50 billion to 250 billion
which left less than 10 banks in the U.S
subject to stricter uh Federal oversight
and allowed Banks under 250 billion in
assets to escape increase scrutiny go
ahead well I just since we're kind of
dipping our our toes into the political
side of things you want to address what
Biden said today I kind of summarized
this whole speech I want to wrap this up
before we go and but here's the thing
with with this part for people to be
thinking about uh if if it it's very
easy for both sides to do this this
isn't a Republican or a Democrat thing
both sides do it where they're like yeah
but this was his fault yeah but it was
that fault and probably everybody in
this room guilty of doing this before
here's a challenge though for how long
did Biden's Administration have control
of the house senate and to be able to do
how long well if they had it for two
years how come they didn't do anything
with this you had two years it's plenty
of time so if if you're saying well you
know it's his fault well it kind of
becomes your fault because you could
have actually done something about it
for two years and you never thought
about this so if that's the case whose
fault is it really or can we just set
this thing aside and say let's deal with
this direct to make sure this doesn't
happen again to another bank today but
but my biggest concern of this before we
go to the Biden
here's my concern
so my concern uh uh I'm kind of debating
in my head and I'm going back and forth
okay and I'm trying to not stick to one
side of the argument on one end I
understand the frustration of people
saying hey capitalism for the you know
poor and socialism for the rich I get it
and on the other side I'm like okay
we do need more Regional Banks
we need more Banks period okay
this crisis to be honest with you just
made chase a lot stronger right if you
think about this this crisis how many
people on America had this conversation
three nights ago husband and wife that
are in bed they're having this
conversation together hey babe you have
a uh babe the bank we're with is it one
of the bigger Banks or is the regional
let me find out babe it's a regional are
we what kind of we were a community oh
but did you did you see what's going on
look let's just be safe and go to one of
the bigger guys who do you think should
go to I don't know Larry my cousin said
go to Bank of America all right Larry go
to Bank of America hey Johnny is at
Chase let's go to Chase how many people
you think in the last week that's the
data I would want to know how many
people left smaller Banks to go to the
bigger Banks that's the risk now some
people may say well that's the right
move to make that is the exact way it
needs to be we need to go there let me
ask you this other question do you think
Tesla
forced other car makers to innovate
faster
do you think Tesla was good for the
economy the answer is what of course it
was absolutely it made everybody say we
better get our [__] together before this
guy
it's our lunch right do we think we we
did a Rob what did we do two weeks ago
when we're talking about the weapon
manufacturers where we showed how they
went from 51 uh uh companies down to
five do you know which one I'm talking
about the javelin it's a lateral chart
this way where it goes you end up with
only Boeing and Lockheed and do you
remember that it was 51 if you can look
it up see if you can find it it was 51
companies that we had 45 years ago where
the market could compete to see who to
get their weapons from who to get there
you know anything they wanted and it
went from 51 to 40 to 30 to 20 to now
five well the fewer we have the less
competition there is so there's more
bullion the fewer Banks we have Believe
It or Not socialists want that they want
it to be nationalized banking they want
that that's more of a control of course
that's more of a controlled by the US
government single-payer healthcare is by
far the worst think it is by far the
worst thing for you and I because they
get to bully us so again as much as this
is if I'm on the Democratic side and I
kind of want to get my the top five
banks to get stronger guess what I'm
doing right now this is exactly what I'm
doing right now get your money out of
regionals this is exactly can you zoom
in please thanks for finding it Rob if
you can zoom in a little bit look at
this this is showing we used to have 50
plus companies in 1980 to buy uh uh uh
you know Aerospace any kind of weapons
anything we wanted down from 1980 25
Lockheed Boeing Raytheon Northrop and
General Dynamics if we go the way we're
going right now and the big Banks use
this crisis we all know the Same by Rahm
Emanuel never let a crisis go to waste
if they use this crisis this is a great
season for the bigger Banks the bigger
bullies to eliminate a lot of the
community and a lot of the regional
competition yeah that's what I'm
concerned about it's time seen in retail
though I mean he used to be mom and pop
shops all over the country and now it's
Amazon Walmart and Target if you're
locking Sam's and Sam so is
consolidation that bad of a thing in
general or is it depending on the second
an area that you need Innovation it is
you know but so so innovation ideas your
banks are important they're they're part
of the fabric of life you go to your
local bank you have relationship with
them you know it's it's important yeah
it's it's a it's uh uh we we as much as
uh you know from the safety standpoint
the average person could say that's
exactly why I'm going to take my bank
you know my money when go to a uh bigger
one it is not going to long-term workout
for uh everyone there you do not want
that if you look at the numbers I looked
it up earlier a Community Bank in
America we have 2258 Community Banks in
America this is ranges 10 billion to 100
billion that's what they're cons the
Community Banks are that size uh large
banks in America we have a 38 of them
this is banks that are worth 100 billion
or more I think uh Chase if you can pull
it up you had an earlier Rob it's a 3.2
trillion dollar Bank uh 3.2 trillion
dollars and there you go chase is 3.2
trillion dollars in assets then it's B
of A City look it even Wells is uh at
the top they don't put it as safety all
the way at the top U.S go all the way to
the bottom until it gets to 100 billion
if you can do that to see how many we
got boom boom Silicon Valley keep going
yeah there's 38 of them that we have and
in regionals we only got 27 of them
um Rob scroll back up a little bit let
me just say the top ten
got it golden side we need we need more
competition we definitely need more
competition the last thing we need is
consolidation yeah we do not need
consolidation if you want to go into uh
uh President Biden gave a speech earlier
today I think it was four minutes and 10
seconds give or take he talked about how
deposits will be there okay uh he talked
about the problems with bank he brought
up Dodd-Frank on what they did and how
he blamed Trump and he talked about
unemployment under four percent for
straight months and he talked 14
straight months and he talked about
protecting depositors so it's a very
much quick four minutes ten seconds he
also took credit for 12 million jobs
created which is put back the ones that
went shut down that came back I mean
yeah that's a very ridiculous statement
to make I'm sorry I just took notes down
specifically regarding the bank run and
Silicon Valley Bank he said the FDIC
took control of all assets for the banks
and it by the way it wasn't just um
Silicon Valley Bank what's what's the
Regional Bank that that also just went
under silvergate so no no not so Brigade
was a week and a half ago and they were
a crypto bank got it so here's some of
the highlights of what Biden say all
customers are going to be protected and
will have access to their money there's
going to be no losses to taxpayers
that's you know something he wanted to
point out and we talked about this
earlier where these fees are coming from
all fees we paid by the what the banks
pay into this FDIC fund
um that all management from these banks
will be fired and the investors into
these banks will not be protected and
obviously his overall goal here is to
eliminate any stress and people freaking
out for these Bank runs we were
discussing earlier so it was interesting
to me that he used it to point blame but
the blame is is misappropriated here
let's understand what happened
the reason why the FED okay so we have a
mismatch in duration that happened
because the Fed was extremely aggressive
why was the FED extremely aggressive
because they were overly accommodative
and culpable as well was government
which was overly stimulative in
combination they created this inflation
so you have the arsonist is now become
the firefighter so this is what the
problem is now by the way what the FED
did today I applaud them they had to
save the depositors I agree with that
but their moves to maniacally increase
rates that's like if somebody heaven
forbid if somebody's ill and you say
okay I'm going to give you some medicine
five minutes later you're not better I'm
gonna give you another dose I'm gonna
give you another dose I'm gonna this is
what they're doing because it takes a
while for this to happen I've got some
stuff on inflation that they're trying
to fight if you ever want to take a look
at it up there that shows inflation's
going to come down if they just
understood how it worked and if they
just saw what causes it to come down
since you brought up job market why
don't you go to the slides with the job
market you see they got some data I
don't know robots
so the FED thinks that the job Market's
so great you got James Bullard you got
all of them on Parade say we got blowout
jobs number BS okay number one in
January showed 517 000 job Creations
that is not for real what they have what
we had was we had a seasonal adjustment
the numbers showed we lost 2.5 million
jobs but they said you know January we
usually use 3 million so poof 500 000
jobs created we did not create those but
what's even more egregious take a look
Rob just scroll through real quick to
the next one I want to show you so this
is the 517 right it really would have
been 2.5 million losses on the next one
and go ahead and scroll through if you
can
and when you when you I wanted to show
you the thing from the BLS just go to
the very next slide just yeah just
Advance it to the next one you see the
bottom left it says the arrow I don't
know if you can see there yeah just
Advance it to the very next slide there
you go at the bottom there you see what
says 2.5 million losses that's from the
BLS you can't play with that now look at
the next one the next one's absolutely
crazy Pat
look at these numbers guys yes Bureau of
Labor Statistics right it's our
government folks that's our government
so take a look at what they showed from
the household survey which as you all
know that's when you zoom in Rob that's
where you get the unemployment rate yeah
there you go they claimed in January we
created 894 000 jobs but what they did
was they made an adjustment called a
population control effect what was that
they picked up some undocumented workers
from early 2022. now any of us logically
wouldn't you just wouldn't you just go
back and say oh let's revise the numbers
no no Pat you know what they did
although they were never created in
January 2023 they put 810
000 jobs as created in January 2023
that's why the unemployment rate went
down instead of going up without that
right well you're you're kidding no
that's right from the BLS
so those 810 were created in 2022 but
they you did put it in 2023. now I don't
want to this came out February 3rd guess
what happened four days later by the way
what was the big 510 no the uh State of
the Union Address was four days later
okay so now who knows if they're related
I'm not going to say they are they are
and I just think it's kind of
coincidental but now when we take a look
at something like this that was what
happened in January let's go to
February's numbers February's numbers
were I thought I think very indicative
if you wouldn't mind just go right to
the next slide brother so this shows you
what it would have been it would have
been 3.9 percent without the seasonal
adjustment instead of 3.4 now in
February's numbers here's what we got it
showed 311 go to the very next slide if
you can 311
000 jobs created right but you see on
the bottom in yellow there was a big
jump in this one category that says if
you're unemployed for five weeks or less
that jumped by 343
000 people so go to the next slide this
kind of illustrates it so that's a
bucket that bucket jumped by 343 000. so
what goes into the bucket people that
just got unemployed what drains the
bucket if you either got another job or
you're unemployed less than five weeks
if the job market is so hot we know that
the jobless claims reportedly that week
were only 194 000 near very very low so
you're not getting the you're not
getting the inflow into the bucket but
it's not draining because people either
aren't getting jobs or they're F or
they're they're pretty be in the
position here where they're staying
unemployed that's why you see this going
up
that's so wild that they they presented
the way they do to say it's the lowest
in how many years 57 years 50 something
years hey it's the lowest and this is
lowest than that so okay so so Barry if
what you're saying is true and let's
just say it is based on the numbers
you're given here it's not like we're
you're you're getting the number from a
a survey then that means the economy is
worse than it really is is that a fair
assessment we have less full-time jobs
now than we did back in May of 2022.
much of the job gains are part-time
workers much of the job gains are people
working well we have less full-time
workers
that's not good now Pat the next one's
going to really blow your mind check
this out now we got all these job gains
right go to the very next slide if you
can please rob this one's really
interesting do you see that chart on the
bottom there yes that chart on the
bottom shows covid yeah but what these
are is hospitality and Leisure workers
right this has been the engine of growth
sure most of the job Gates have come
from this category but it's not real
growth you're just putting these poor
people back to work right but if you
notice we're almost back to Trend do you
see that how much we're even lower than
that but but eventually let's say we put
everybody back there's not that much
more juice left to be squeezed here
right and if you take a look at the job
openings and labor turnover known as the
jolts report this is job postings Yep
this category last month was down 194
000. so this tells me the labor Market's
about to take a negative turn
if the labor and I'm with you I I'm I'm
fully there and I I've been saying this
for a few months where I think that's
that's the number no one's talking about
okay but let's go there let's go there
you your background for people that
don't know your background I mean if
you've been on you've been on a couple
other times we had you on a podcast your
background for people that don't know
this you uh have won the crystal ball
award for the most accurate real estate
forecaster in 2017 this is through
Zillow in 2019 and 2020. you're the only
three time I believe right okay so
you've been able to successfully
forecast what's going to be happening
that's kind of how what you're known for
with that part of your success you've
done other things but this is specific
to this so we have a great great team
it's not just me our team you know
it's impossible for you to do it by
yourself you need the right people to
give you the data but still your name is
tied to you based on the data you get
these are the forecasts you made
if these numbers are the numbers you're
showing and we just had what's going on
right now with Silicon Valley Bank okay
and Powell is going to be sitting here a
lot of people were saying well before
Silicon Valley Bank it was going to
raise the rate by half a point and maybe
another half a point and then back to
back you know quarter quarter now some
people are saying he's not going to do
anything let alone some people are
saying he may even cut and lower it so
what is your forecast on based on this
based on inflation based on Silicon
Valley Bank what do you think Powell's
going to do next with interest rates
okay so interest rates is very
interesting because mortgage rates are
going to be more determined by inflation
and the FED will have more of an impact
on shorter term rates and also the stock
market so I believe that the FED will
more than likely have a difficult time
hiking more than a quarter percent I
think a half a percent is off the table
I think maybe zero I don't think they'll
cut at this meeting but I think that
it'll either be a quarter or no move at
all maybe a pause just to see things
settle down because remember the fed by
moving rates up too quickly has caused
these imbalances things will break now
the problem with the FED is that they
don't look at inflation mortgage rates
and real estate for that matter will be
highly motivated and driven by inflation
I have a couple of slides there Rob
that's probably going to be in the
beginning there's there's a slide there
how mortgage rates follow inflation if
you could see the correlation
um okay this shows you what happens
during recession this shows you mortgage
rates go down during every recession so
that that we I believe we're headed for
a recession as a matter of fact while
we're on the topic of recession look at
the next slide very very interesting Rob
uh go up one I'm sorry go up one yeah
why haven't we not been in a recession
maybe we are we already had two quarters
of negative GDP Pat but take a look at
credit card balances the the um gray
area that's the recession followed by
the pandemic every but he forgets we had
a recession before the pandemic two
months before it but credit card
balances on top were way up and the
savings rate was like 10 percent that
big spike in savings was the stimulus
that went into people's savings account
fake but but look at what they did with
it they wisely paid off their credit
cards they couldn't spend it on anything
else notice how they drain their savings
and it paid off credit cards then we got
another stimulus check but we spent that
even faster but what did we do we bought
a lot of name brand stuff that we got
don't worry got another one coming boom
and then once that stopped people liked
that stimulus lifestyle how do you keep
it going Pat you charge up your credit
cards which have low balances and you
drain your savings we've gone from a 10
savings account to three and a half
percent and we now owe more on our
credit cards than ever in history even
this has to have a limit sometimes and
that's why we hit the wall 940 billion
dollars credit card
savings rate was the lowest we've had
since uh it's a long time since 17 years
ago I think was 2.4 percent savings rate
in February I want to say these are
scary numbers to see that so again
saying that saying that
Powell uh uh it's almost cornered now
with this crisis to have to either not
touch it or lower it Tom do you think
Powell is gonna still raise rates do you
think he's gonna delay it 30 60 days to
see how the Market's gonna react to this
to see if any other banks are going to
react to this what do you think Powell's
going to do next well right now I think
it it depends on the next uh 48 Hours uh
today was a rough day on the market but
not a cataclysmic day on the market uh I
I'm I'm with Barry I think a half points
off the table now I think it's a quarter
point but if there is any jitteriness in
the next 48 hours in banking stocks like
there's Fallout they still need to find
a buyer for Maine Silicon Valley Bank
remember they only found hsbc'd by the
UK one and PNC on Sunday night said nah
I'm out they wanted PNC trust and U.S
bank which are the top three banks at
the next tier they wanted one of those
preferably PNC except a stronger balance
sheet to pick up United United States
svb if nobody picks that up you know
it's gonna I think you're gonna see
Jitters and if there are Jitters I think
Powell may go zero next Thursday it's
the 22nd yeah it's like yeah we got a
week right yeah it's what's today okay
so we got a week in a day so next
Wednesday if it's jittery next Wednesday
Powell may go zero but I believe he's
only doing 25. okay so here's a question
you got to ask how many people
and how much you think Powell
communicates with Biden with Yellen how
much communication you think there's
with them and Biden right now I think
sends 14 text messages a day and
receives 1400 okay so how quickly you
think after this event I'm not being
funny I'm saying you know I think
everybody's hammering I got you Tom so
how much you think right now a emergency
call or meeting has been made with all
of them to say the following hey Jerome
we know we can't tell you what to do but
here's what I want you to be thinking
about we both know what's going to
happen if you raise the rates a half a
point
the reason why this happened with
Silicon Valley Bank is because the rates
increasing the way it did and that kind
of messed them up and I got track how
many more Banks like that are out there
I don't know but if you increase it the
way you were gonna increase it a point
to point and a half over the next four
five six months this may be the time for
you to pump the brakes at least for 90
days to see how this reacts do you think
that's the responsible call for yelling
and Biden to make to Powell I think
Yellen made that call on Friday
afternoon after They seized svb in the
morning they knew where the dominoes
were going they were watching the market
I believe that call happened before
dinner time on Friday can I think well I
agree with you I mean who knows but I
agree with that I think your guess is a
very very good one
um I want to show you where I think
inflation's going and I want to show you
why I think that the FED if they only
would pay attention to this they would
understand that they've already done
more than enough and inflation's rolling
over already can we please go to the
Chart go up a little bit and I want to
pull this chart up that shows enforce
you're putting that up Pat I think right
there right I think you made the right
right for the roller coaster right
before the roller coaster okay so what
this shows you are shelter costs now
when you look at CPI the Consumer Price
Index the core CPI is what's important
because that's how you determine
monetary policy core takes away food and
energy the FED can't influence a bird
fluid egg prices going up weather oil
production so they take that out they
say let's look at the core rate because
we can influence this
43 43.2 to be exact of the core CPI is
shelter costs so that's rent and owner's
equivalent rent the way that the FED
looks at housing and CPI looks at
housing is as a service as you know they
don't it doesn't matter what your
mortgage rate is it doesn't matter what
your home value is is what am I paying
in rents and what can I rent my home for
so that's what they look at take a look
at what's happening in this area it was
18 a little over a year ago now it's
going up by three percent but the
problem is there's a lag they count the
last 12 months so it takes time so if
you just click to the next one it's like
a it's like a like a roller coaster you
got to put it in play mode though
because there's an animation too it's
like real-time shelter cluster coming
down but the way it's in CPI go to the
next one just put it in play mode
and uh go to that next slide now Advance
it forward
if you press hit the forward Arrow
it's not doing anything all right so go
to go to the next slide and just put
that one into play mode
yeah for whatever reason Rob is doing it
right it's just for whatever reason yeah
computer doesn't react to it it did it
again two weeks ago I think Rob
so Rob if you if you put that in maybe
it's because it's in full screen look at
the go with the book One Rob
with the one that's to the left of full
screen are you able to get out of this
Rob or no Rob please tell me you're not
he's got he's got he's got it he's gotta
go you got the right one Rob just see if
you can go to the very next slide you
see the arrow on the bottom left
there you go keep going one more Arrow
now
okay that will go back one
if you could play this one I want to
show you this particular slide but if
you hit if you hit
um forward on that one it's not gonna
happen there it is okay so you see the
Blue Line there yeah that's the way it
is within the CPR report it's saying
shelter costs are going up 7.9 because
of the lag in real time it's three
percent there's a mathematical
calculation we all could do guys take a
look if you take the difference between
the two which is 4.9 and you take the
weighting of 43 CPI core is currently
overstated by two percent very
explain what your ex mortgage rates have
to come down to the fifth grade
long-term rates have to come down
because inflation's already coming down
just be patient and wait for this lag
okay so there we go let's let's can I
just ask you that you're saying that
mortgage rates are going to come down
they have to come down because inflation
Barry some people will say you're
talking like a mortgage broker hell of a
good one you were with GMAC national
sales director the last time you stopped
doing loans was 07 you're like one of
the greatest uh Lo's that we've had in
the market so a lot of time when
Realtors or loan officers say that
you're in the space the the counter
argument to that would be okay we we saw
what happened when we made money pretty
much cheap for 12 years and then we try
to get off of it you know it it didn't
work for us to do that and right now uh
uh some will still say a lot of
properties are overvalued the amount of
uh how much home values have increased
compared to income has increased it
doesn't match if the saving doesn't
increase at so people can't afford to
buy a house at today's price I have a
chart for that to show you that it's
it's a little bit of an interesting
scenario it's not that right now the
affordability is worse but the
affordability will improve though
Patrick there's how Okay a couple of
things first on this channel isn't when
you say affordability forget about the
charts for a second isn't it when you
say affordability will improve this year
okay so you know what that means to me
that's a very nice way of saying you're
about to lose equity in your home your
property value is going to go down I
think that actually we probably will see
about three percent Nationwide
appreciation this year because the level
of inventory is just so tight we saw
already in January when rates dropped to
about six percent that where there are
multiple offers around the country I'm
not seeing that though and I'll tell you
in January we saw it but not slowed back
but I'm going to tell you from a buyer's
standpoint I'm not seeing that from a
buyer's standpoint I'm not seeing that
I'm seeing from the buyer's standpoint
minus 500 000 minus one million minus
two hundred thousand they lowered it by
another 299 000 no well I mean I don't
know I mean always will be specific
incidences obviously you're right on the
specific instances but if you go by the
Numbers let's just say from the fhfa or
from case Schiller the seasonally
adjusted numbers show that real estate
values from the very Peak after 121
consecutive month rise are down one
percent from fhfa 2.7 from case those
are the numbers from case those are the
best two sources you know what a seller
will say a seller will say Barry I hope
you're right but how come I'm not
getting any offers of qualified buyers
today because I hope you're right
they're hibernating with seven percent
rates but that's why this is so
important but you can we for you to say
guys let's lower the rate it's all going
to work itself out that's the problem
the problem isn't for the Powell is
sitting there saying I I get what you're
saying Barry I understand what you're
saying a lot of loan officers are
getting crushed right now a lot of
Realtors are getting crushed right now I
get it but I can't do this right now
controlled mortgage rates Pat he does
not but mortgage rates are going to
trade and follow inflation long-term
investor the short end of the curve a
hundred percent all the short-term to
follow that but the long end of the
curve won't you so so if that's fair but
that's kind of like me my kid saying
that trust me I'm going to read 100
Pages this week let me play iPad on
Monday I'm telling you I'm going to read
100 Pages by the end of the week because
I'm going to read it just let me play
iPad online I'm like no no that's not
how life works first read 100 Pages then
I'll let you play iPad right first let's
lower inflation then let's lower that's
why it's so important because inflation
on a year-over-year basis it has been
stubborn because the comparisons from
shelter have propped it up but also the
comparisons from where we were a year
ago were relatively high if we take a
look the date that you should be
circling is May 10th on your calendar
that's when we get the inflation data
that begins a string of information May
10th May 10th okay a string of inflation
data that will be lower replacing higher
inflation data from the previous year it
will bring the year over your numbers
down and we'll get the shelter Barry
trust me everybody wants you to be right
I'm not sitting here saying I don't want
you to be right I want you to be right
but the the the market is seeing other
things the market right now when it
comes down to buying car the National
car payment right now is a 911 or 9 20.
just two years ago it was five freaking
75. how the hell is the average American
able to go to that so rates on a million
dollar loan two years ago the payment
was nothing today on a million dollar
loan at the race that I'm getting if I
got a 750 credit score if I can show
everything it's nearly 50 inches higher
these are just income is not increasing
no no income income is by 50 no but it
doesn't have to because you don't use
all of your income to qualify for it so
a couple of points income according to
ADP went up 7.2 percent year over year
car payment went up nearly a hundred
percent you're 100 right college is 500
guys I agree with you I'm not
disagreeing with you I'm not disagreeing
with you it is less affordable however
in an equivalent state of affordability
you had 20 appreciation I'm saying three
percent appreciation and predominantly
due because you have such unbelievably
record low inventory this 578 000 units
for sale in this country I tell you what
here's what I'm going to tell you uh
you're so good I'm gonna do my next
refinance with you okay I don't do loans
this one you may want to do it's going
to be a decent one but no so you know
bear are you getting nominated for
another crystal ball award how does this
work well look well let's see what
happens right with rate so nobody knows
for sure of course could I be wrong of
course I could be wrong however to me
when I look at something like this and I
say okay it appears that inflation
should be coming down historically
mortgage rates or all long rates always
following what I hope what I hope uh
happens
uh with Jerome Powell I hope he doesn't
break okay that's my my fear I hope he
doesn't break you know what I said today
on the Baldwin all these guys are saying
well Patrick but Patrick but Patrick
I said listen is it fair to say that a
crisis happened last week to the economy
yeah it did how the hell is the market
up on Monday
tell me when in your life
something bad happened in your life and
you got rewarded the next day I I don't
do you realize how
that makes no sense there needs to be re
if I don't go to school like it's kind
of like me going to school and I skipped
two weeks straight I don't even go to
class I don't know what my homework is
hey Miss Taylor how are things well
Patrick great job because your great one
from 72 to 91 percent how the hell did
my grade go up how to come to school
last two weeks that's what's going on
right now this is very this is this is
where the average person watches the
market and says I gotta tell you man
this is exactly why I want to have
nothing to do with Finance I'm gonna go
freaking be a construction worker that's
I'm gonna go be a general cop I'm gonna
go be a plumber forget this stuff here
so you mean to tell me the 16 biggest
bank in America goes out of business and
on Monday rather than people panicking
they say bye yeah that makes a lot of
sense to me by the way when we started
the show The Market was up at 3 P.M when
we started it now at the close of the
market the Dow was down 90 points okay
the s p did close uh negative for the
day you know what that means to me no
down 90 points what what is 90 points on
thirty two thousand a lot it's a very
0.45
yeah that's the numbers right there if
you want to look at it NASDAQ was uh
NASDAQ was higher point four five
percent SMP is down 0.15 so basically it
was a nothing Burger in the market today
there's other reasons why the s p by I
there's some technical stuff going on
breaking underneath its 200-day moving
average there's some negatives for the
stock market that I see that could cause
a little heartburn maybe another 10 drop
but you guys remember in 2007 2008 I
mean I was just starting my financial
career I couldn't spell 401K at that
point but we remember just the slow drip
of information boom boom all of a sudden
Layman Brothers is hold on what's going
on here and then and then the Market's
500 points today 500 points today 500
points today and we're seeing any
correlation with what's happening then
with now is there like you know if you
don't learn from history you're destined
to repeat it or or is it too early to
tell what are your thoughts
well like I said I think that I think
maybe the market the stock market the
equity Market appears to me to be a
little bit overextended
um I think that it will likely retest
3500 on the S P but you know it's
Anything could happen in this in this
world right
yeah
uh by the way Rob can you can you try to
find how Bank stocks did today okay Bank
stocks did today I'm curious to know
exactly
uh uh uh oh there you go I just found
this here let's see what it's shown oh
my God right across the board let me
just send this to you and then also Rob
if you can find KBW index that's right
the banking index KBW exactly right uh
I'm gonna send this to you you just see
it right there now remember they have to
pay insurance on all of this so it's
going to be more expensive for them
because they have to pay insurance on
everything above 250. there you go Pat
there's the index 11 down today
uh what is it this is the KBW NASDAQ
Bank index so this is an index fund
1166.
and by the way right at the start it was
stable through the day but see at the
start Wham okay so Chase is down 1.8
Bank of America is down six percent give
or take uh Morgan standing is down 2.29
Wells is down three percent
HSBC is down to Royal Bank of Canada is
down 0.6
uh Goldman Sachs is down 3.71 Charles
Schwab is down 11.57
Citigroup is on 745 let's see any one of
them that's uh big numbers that they
have there's nothing to say here the
Goldman Sachs down 12. oh no three seven
okay that's 12 points by the way Bank of
Nova Scotia shout out to you guys
they're up 0.74 look at Charles Schwab
down 11. I saw that USB USB is 10 down
PNC is down 5.8 5.18 ing okay there you
go truce Financial Corporation nearly 17
so none of these guys very few of them
are down eleven six six but the the fund
is down eleven six six give or take so
this is good it should be like this
there should be a price to be paid right
now people should be a little bit
skeptical people shouldn't be sitting
there saying it kind of worked itself
out but here's the part I guess the
question everybody at the end of the day
has to ask now is this you know the
whole FDIC quarter of a million dollars
okay so if now you're going to come and
protect the positors and you're saying
they should do that fine no problem then
then you have one of two decisions you
guys got to make either one you have to
increase the 250 and put no limit which
is kind of what you're doing right now
or raise it to a number but if you say
250 and you're willing to do that no
limit then it's not really 250 it's just
a wink wink 250. hey be very careful but
don't worry about it we're gonna back
you up even if it's more than two one
part of government will pay you the 250
the other part of government will give
you the rest so what's the right thing
to do do you think that that number
needs to be what Tom what do you think
that number needs to be well I agree
with Mark Cuban and Mark Cuban just said
shouldn't we move this to 500. like a
half a million dollars insured
um I I think that's a rational approach
now I'm all in favor of protecting
depositors I am one not of SVP but um I
am a depositor and I'd love to see
myself protected but I'll tell you what
I don't like what this basically tells
the banks
is that you can be foolish
and the government's going to bail out
your depositors and you only have to
worry about the investors I I just think
when you when you make these bailouts
it's it's a moral hazard but I think it
should be 500 to your core point I think
it should be a little higher than that
um you know it's I think probably a
million is probably more realistic for
today's day and age and what that will
do is if you have money in payroll you
can probably do sweeps you can invest it
in treasuries and then bring it back in
the day before payroll it is the digital
age you could do these things however
um a million would would alleviate for
small businesses the need to kind of go
back and forth with more sophisticated
banking well you know how they say like
to make six figures ain't what it used
to be right so to use that to use that
analogy when did the FDIC 250 000 limit
come into effect how long ago was that
do we know can we google that because if
it was 50 years ago it's not the same
number it was a hundred thousand what if
we adjusted the 250 across time well
exactly I mean it wasn't 100 000 for a
long time was it I'm just trying to look
for I'm sure Rob is on the ball here but
like just like for instance this this uh
this past year we've seen that social
security has increased by like eight
percent to deal with inflation and the
cost of living and CPI and all that I'm
wondering if that same uh metaphor could
be used for
the FDIC and by the way Rob when you do
that can you also run a poll on the
podcast right now since we're on the
topic of what they think it needs to be
increased to should it stay I'm asking
this question on Twitter well keep it at
keep it at 250 okay I'm more towards you
which is I think a million bucks is
enough because we can keep it at a
million for 10 years 20 years and you
just kind of keep it at that number and
also Pat you don't want it to be too
much more than that because then you got
to pay insurance on that where that
would put some banks that are smaller in
a tough position mm-hmm
and you bring up a good point there
Barry a lot of these bank accounts are
companies businesses I don't know too
many just Average Joe's just with
quarter Mill in the bank maybe a million
bucks in the bank
um but a lot of these are companies that
that don't want to diversify imagine if
you're a company with five million
dollars in assets you don't want to deal
with 10 different banks
like kind of what Cuban said you have
all these fees it'd be great for the
banks but you just want to consolidate
keep it simple uh that's a good point
right especially if it's payroll that
you're dealing with again you could
avoid that by putting it in treasuries
and back and forth but that puts strain
on a small company you know you got a
bookkeeper or one you know if you're a
company with 15 20 people it's it's it's
it's not easy also in treasuries isn't
there sort of a lock-up period you can't
just you can do like you can do it where
it can match
um your payroll periods you could you
could stagger it yeah but that's what it
gets very complicated yes yeah exactly
keep it simple stupid the kids principle
yeah running that pole to see what's
going to happen with those numbers but
uh a couple couple things here that
we're looking at with uh savings rate I
don't know if you guys saw this your
Wall Street Journal uh Savers pile money
into bank CDs as rates top five percent
did you see that where banks are uh
topping five percent and uh By the way
when is the last time we had five
percent I think the last yes well I can
tell you who it was I remember who ran a
commercial every day talking about five
percent four point five percent five
point five percent you know what the
company was ING Direct I don't know if
you remember that Americans are
rediscovering CDs as a safe haven amid
High inflation Rising interest rates and
economic anxiety balances NCD soaring
from 36 and a half billion dollars in
April
is this correct
damn
did you see these numbers balances
increased in CDs from 36.5 billion
dollars in April of last year to 418
billion Dollars January of this year no
time that's 12x no just 400 yeah 418
billion dollars banks are competing for
deposits again uh after several years of
showing little inclination to do so the
top Builder nationally available
12-month cities are now between five and
five and a quarter which is
significantly higher than the average
yield on a 12-month CD currently at 1.59
C these work best for relatively
short-term savings goals such as down
payment or on a house it's crucial to
shop around and consider but Pat that's
the problem is that you're pulling money
out of deposits and you're putting them
in CDs yes and now you have long-dated
maturities that there's a mismatch yep
that's a good point what do you think
about it Tom I I well first of all I
agree about with the mismatch but the
second part is I think there's a there's
your there's your answer mortgage
originations are at their lowest point
in 28 years
um and where's the down payment money I
think you're seeing a lot of this is
look this is liquid money Americans have
that a significant amount of that you
just described is basically down payment
money that's on the sideline this is and
I read last Friday the most rate
sensitive General the 35 year old home
buyer today is the most sensitive that
generation
um most rate sensitive buyer in the
history
because their lives they've never seen
this they don't understand that it was
perfectly reasonable to have a six
hundred thousand dollar home with a six
percent loan on it with reasonable
property tax District they don't
understand that that's perfectly
realistic they've been living in a
payment economy from their car to
everything else they've had that has
been so artificial because of zerp and
so now it's all coming home to roost and
they're like six percent good Lord and
their grandparents are saying why are
you screaming I want to show a scary
number I want to show you a scary number
I want to show you scary numbers
somebody just sent this here to me Saint
Pat take a look at this here uh uh and
this is by Nick Nick James who's if
you're watching this this is you send it
to me so zoom in here FDIC a goal all
the way to the bottom what their balance
sheet is and how much they're protecting
right now the amount of money they have
if you look at that closely they have
125 billion dollars you know how much
you're protecting
9.9 trillion dollars
did you did you hear that yeah say that
one more time okay yeah
a lot of numbers on this page right has
a 125 billion dollars in their balance
but they're insured deposits the quarter
million dollars on the millions of
accounts that are out there they're
protecting
9.926 trillion dollars
what this is shown is the fact that you
can't just say we got you don't worry
about it no you don't have the money
you don't have the money by the way you
may be able to do it for One svb Bank
maybe for a second bank if all of a
sudden you get a third fourth fifth
seventh eight nine tenth they they can't
do anything at that point if this
happens so you're saying they weren't
just concerned about the poor citizens
with deposits at svb that they looked at
their own dashboard and said good Lord
we better make sure there's no runs on
banks Monday that's right Tom that's
exactly right but by the way you know
what that number is do you know what
that number is like what percentage of
the insured deposits they have what is
is it 1.26 it's 1.26 percent
yeah that's that sounds about right let
me do you understand what I'm asking
here yeah what they have they only have
1.26 yeah 900 would be 10 so yeah it's
about one and a quarter percent yeah oh
that's it the reserve ratio okay so that
should answer the question here on
whether they're saying well I just asked
the question right now on Twitter I said
keep it at 250 500 1 million Unlimited
uh uh 36 is the highest said keep it at
250. 500 000 is the lowest 12 1 million
is the second lowest 23 but do you know
29 said keep it unlimited you know what
that tells you most people have no clue
that the number and the kind of funds
that we have how the hell are we going
to be able to protect this unlimited
when you only have 1.26 percent of the
dollar a month insured right now the
FDIC
can I tell you actually why low key I
kind of really appreciate what's
happening right now with the Silicon
Valley Bank because it's it's you know
this whole return to normalcy and all
that
these are the types of conversations
that we need to be having As Americans
with the debt that we're taking on in
America right and the situations that
are going on in the banks over the last
few years the the whether it's cultural
issues like the wokism stuff and lgbtq
and critical race Theory and all these
then it became abortion and covid and
Jabs and oh nfts in meta world and I'm
buying real estate in the [__]
metaverse who gives a [__] this is what
makes America tick these are the types
of issues that we really need to focus
on great point and get on the same page
here not all the nonsensical stuff like
I just bought an nft in the metaverse
with a coveted mask attached to it like
that's like let's get past that and get
back to reality here I think that's very
important absolutely I just ask you to
be a little sensible for people that are
going through challenging times and your
body have a little sympathy and
compassion for the folks that bought
land at 4.8 million dollars
versus absolutely have a little bit of
respect you know what
a lot of people right now okay so so
next question next question uh Tom the
market today is reacting to what's going
on okay a day two days three days a week
two weeks three weeks four weeks
I'm going to go strictly to you here do
you think if if I were to ask you the
chances of this happening with another
bank that's worth more than 100 billion
dollars the 38 banks that are worth 100
billion dollars or more what is the
likelihood of another bank or two also
going through this the next few months
give me the percentage what do you think
the percentages
you can say you know whatever percentage
if you're betting man what do you think
it is well knowing what we know
um
and zurp for so long and such a level of
irresponsibility
I think it's probably about a 25 chance
you think that high
yeah oh my God I think there's probably
a 25 well here's here's it 25 chance of
like a run on the bank and everything
else going like this or do I think
there's a 25 chance that there's another
bank like signature that gets a tap on
the shoulder different question is there
another bank like signature that that
The Regulators are gonna like real up
and say okay guys we got to read those
freaking footnotes and we got to read
everything right now is there another
bank out there that they're gonna call
her like they did the New York other
bank no one knew about the southern New
York Bank it was an oh by the way point
in the Sunday news cycle right what's
this other big signature well what we
were talking to Silicon Valley Bank we
already knew this was coming and so we
kind of sent a couple of the boys over
there to kind of pull them into line so
do I think there's one more I think
there's a 25 chance that that's a more
pretty high number right there I think
that's a very high number yeah Barry I
think you may be a little bit more
conservative than that where are you at
so if you were there's a chart I have
that I'm gonna I'm gonna send
um I'm gonna send it to you uh to you
Pat I'm gonna I'm gonna text it to her
should I should I send it to Rob was
that the best way to go here all right
I'm I'm texting it to you it gives a
scoreboard so take a look at that I just
texted it to you rob
um I think if the FED did not step in
there'd be a hundred percent chance of
this happening but now that the FED
stepped in with this facility I think
that it is unlikely that it does happen
in my you know so I would agree if the
FED didn't do it very very yeah First
Republic jumping around on one leg now
exactly they're amputated one leg
exactly just to be clear here you're
saying there'd be 100 chance of another
bank I agree with them yes that's what
I'm thinking about I agree with them in
a way where
yeah take a look at that that's you
that's your school you know why you know
why he's why I'm on the side of what
he's saying right now if they don't do
anything about it because
what this decision did to the other
third 27th to the other 26 regionals and
the number of communities and all the
smaller Banks I as a depositor said it's
going to be fine yes the fdit FDIC is
going to step in but here's a question
just like we just found out what
percentage of depositors you think know
that the FDIC on their balance sheet
only has 125 billion to protect 9.9
trillion what percentage of depositors
in the marketing thing no zero I didn't
know that yeah we all didn't know that I
just learned right now myself so so
that's the part so you're 25 even with
it happening where are you at now that
the FED did step in but what would you
be at would you say five percent ten
percent yeah unlikely
um because I think there's facilities to
get you out of it
wait I don't have no idea but I mean you
guys have a lot of credibility here what
I would like to avoid is sort of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy and be like
these banks are definitely going under
and then the narrative kind of starts
happening with that I like that the fact
that the government is stepping in and
ensuring people everything's okay right
why you were gonna if you were that I
thought you were gonna ask me
like do you know of one and I was going
to say First Republic but beyond that I
agree I think there's a lot of banks out
there right now that are trying to make
it right if they're not right and they
also know that the depositors are safe
because
grandma has put this thing out there 25
billion dollars in the btfp this let me
ask you guys a question Barry it's for
you so this is sort of a naive question
because I don't work on bank balance
sheets but
you know if you're a Chase if you're at
Goldman if you're in well as a boa like
you're talking about the the Silicon
Valley Bank didn't have the the risk
officer or the risk manager even working
for the last eight months
these Banks I assume are like alert Red
Alert Red Alert like let's make sure
we're solvent like are there there's
protocols in place that banks are making
sure that they're good to go I I think
that uh hopefully that's something that
everybody is looking into and if if I
mean they probably already know where
all the bodies are buried right now I
think everybody else has this line of
sight to see that these investments in
supposedly risk-free assets that aren't
subject to the haircut because of uh of
the fact that interest rates have gone
up I think people are looking at what is
the percentage of loans that you have
that were at very low yields that Mark
to Market if Mark to market right now
how much would your actual
solvency B yeah and this goes back to
Pat's Four Points of capitalism and the
freedom to fail
and the metaphor of the entire 2008
crisis was what too big to fail so I'm
wondering with all this consolidation of
Banks and Pat saying that we need more
competition in Banks what happens if one
of these massive Banks fails like what
happens to the U.S at that point well no
that that part is when others will come
in and pick them up for pennies on a
dollar right
you saw 308 312 whatever the number was
how much they were around they were
bought for buck nine billion nine that's
nothing right that's Pennies on the
dollar WAMU went like this to Chase and
how uncomfortable is a CEO sitting right
here three four months ago the most
uncomfortable meeting that we had
because he thought he was coming here to
talk about seven keys for success and we
talked about how the hell did WAMU one
of the biggest banks in America
go down the way it did so yeah that that
to me
you know there's a part where if you're
looking at this and whether you agree
with the decision or not
you just have to make sure there's not
three or four other Banks out there
because if there is Tom FDIC cannot do
nothing it'll be another quantitative
easing 3.0 4.0 whatever you want to call
it super tarp and this time around it
will not be
small number this time around it's going
to be a couple trillion dollars if that
happens again and the banks every day
and this has been part of glass-steagall
and a lot of other regulation the banks
at the end of each day have to post to
The Regulators uh balance sheet with
certain tests right and so there is
visibility out there that's why the
Regulators jumped in on Silicon Valley
Bank on not just a crashing stock price
they jumped in on because the run on the
bank it's actually they were almost kind
of blind to the public activity because
they look at the sheet at the end of the
day and they're like sweet Jesus you
know these guys are dead and The
Regulators can only jump in on the
regulatory violation and so and that's
when it happened and when there was a 42
billion dollar request and then all of a
sudden they're negative 958 just under a
billion at the end of the day and
they're like okay not only have you flip
the circuit breaker if flipped all of
them you know and here we come
and so that happens every day it's not
like there's no visibility this this has
nothing to do with anything but it does
we know what's happening next year we
know right now Vivek ramaswani is going
out there making his rounds and he's
getting on this space he's working his
tail he's everywhere right the guys like
this he's hustling you can tell he's out
there you saw Pence make a comment that
he made he's still on the January six
comments that he made about I don't know
if you guys saw that or not but you know
it's going to go down as one of the
worst embarrassing what did he call it
he threw Trump under the bus in a major
history he won't treat him fair he
endangered my family yeah something like
that that Penn said right who
is going to use this crisis the most and
who will this crisis help the most does
this help Biden does this help Trump
does this help DeSantis does this help a
candidate from the outside that's going
to come in who does it help or it's too
early to tell what do you think
Tom I'll go to you first uh I think this
helps DeSantis for three reasons the
mainstream media once again Trump
derangements syndrome they're out there
attacking him saying it's all his fault
and it's irrefutably on Biden's watch
and so the guy that's standing over here
that there's really nothing stuck to him
is
the guy just got a benefit out of a
couple big crisises and rock throwing
and so I think that helps DeSantis I
think uh not that he's running I don't
think Bernie Sanders is running but this
entire storyline just screams the the
Millionaires and the billionaires get
all the favors out of here and the
little guy that the whole Main Street
versus Wall Street narrative right there
I mean this is Silicon Valley Bank
getting bailed out I mean in the heart
of tech Valley out there and this is
just is going to go right to the squad
and AOC and they don't care about you
they don't care about Main Street all
they care about is Wall Street Silicon
Valley and it's just gonna be the same
old you know Bernie narrative and by the
way that's that was the infancy of the
Occupy Wall Street movement how this all
started and he's kind of not wrong uh to
call out this sort of crony capitalism I
don't know I I think that
um
I think that because this can affect
people who are on a salary that are
getting paid I think it's a little bit
of a different thing and because
you do have pain from people who made
the investments in the bank the the the
big the big money who were the investors
the stockholders they got wiped out you
know the bondholders probably get a lot
of pain that they're going to feel so I
I don't think that that's the way that
it'll be told in certain media Outlets I
don't think they'll tell the whole story
I think they'll do exactly what you're
saying I think you're right that that's
the spin that they'll try to put on it
but this is not a Donald Trump problem
he did not create this you know this was
a Dodd-Frank issue and this was a lack
of oversight issue which is for the last
couple of years under the current
Administration I mean the the balance
sheet of this Bank turned last year this
was a very profitable Bank these
Investments turned based upon what the
FED did under this administration's
watch so I know they're going to try and
spin it the best that they can but
anybody who can see through that can see
that this is clearly
on it's clearly on the FED it's clearly
on the additional stimulus that cause
the inflation it's and it's it's on the
lack of oversight on what these Banks
were able to do at the end of the day
isn't it on specifically Silicon Valley
Bank more than anything right
they were allowed yes it is of course
but they were allowed to not have to
disclose these as tier one Capital
losses because of the Dodd-Frank ruling
uh Rob just pulled us up around the
sentence blames wall culture for Silicon
Valley Bank collapse reminds him of
financial crisis
and
um Bernie Madoff he's trying to jump on
top and jump on it the only reason I'm
laughing is because Rhonda Sanders is
going to blame everything on world
culture that's his entire ammo this Bank
they're so concerned with the DEA and
politics and all kinds of stuff I think
that they really diverted from uh
focusing on their core Mission uh uh
while noting that he didn't have any
similar information on certain Florida
Banks or any concerns on Runs run on
banks in the state by the way can you
pull up what uh the chief uh uh I don't
know if it's the Chief Operating Officer
but one of the c-suites or could have
been the VP what the lady said in her
profile you have it I send it to it's a
picture that you have it's one of the
three pictures that they're right there
go back this is the head of Financial
Risk Management and model risk Silicon
Valley Bank UK limited the phrase you
can be what uh you can't see resonates
with me as a queer person of color and a
first generation immigrant from a
working class background there were not
many role models for me to see growing
up I feel privileged to co-chair the
lgbtq
I don't even know ERG and help spread
awareness of livid queer experiences
partnering with charitable organizations
and above all create a sense of
community for our community employees
and allies this is the head of Financial
Risk Management
and Moder risk Silicon Valley Bank UK
Limited I mean what that profile has to
do with how good you are at your job I
don't know
but listen go for it hey I think
Valentine's gonna rock because I'm half
a Syrian half Armenian born and raised
in Iran lived at a refugee camp in
Germany and I can relate to people whose
fathers is a 99 Cent Store cashier and
parents gotta do can you imagine if I
put that on my profile and you're also a
married man who's straight and you have
kids and you like coaching baseball and
what does that have to do well for her
that could work against me to her that
could work again don't assume that it's
a her because her name his name is Jay
oh my God
our guy posted a picture on pbd podcast
the other day if you go to Twitter
profile he's so funny the stuff he posts
uh uh uh he posted he says uh only kids
from 90s will remember this I don't know
if you saw this or not Rob this meme
even made me crack up I almost peed my
pants when I saw this I'm like this
guy's funny I'll send it to you here
okay go two more lower it should come up
right there two more lower uh right
there only 90s kids will remember this
yeah I remember that yeah well it's
crazy I was I was uh I was having lunch
yesterday with a buddy Oliver if you're
watching this and he said that he was
traveling
and there was a drop down box just like
this and he had to enter his pronoun had
to he was traveling and it was I was
like what'd you put in he's like well I
put in you know he is he's like I don't
I've never done this in my life but it
was all the he she we they us who what
when when they
lgtqg and he's like dude I'm just trying
to get a flight here but honestly if you
think about it to some people it's
intimidating that the American alphabet
has how many letters in it
26 yeah and that's already intimidating
yeah I know right now you're throwing
pluses and decimals and Pi signs holy
[__] Only the Strong will survive with
that many acronyms I was in the military
we had to remember acronyms but this one
makes it even tougher uh I want to do
one last story before we wrap up one
last story before we wrap up here let me
see what I got here if we got any
stories for today or we keep it for
tomorrow tom do you have any stories
can we tell a story maybe about why like
the future might look bright and we're
not all just gonna go down with the show
you know what that's a good question
when you when you ask that a girl uh uh
post a question in Instagram uh about
what's going on I posted a video and she
says and you still think the future
looks bright and I said only for those
who view themselves as Leaders very
simple what do you mean by that someone
asked a leader never sees himself or
herself as a victim put them in any
situation yes it's gonna to be painful
season yes going to go through tough
times you know in our company right now
it's so funny I started I mean it's not
funny I was a 23 year old guy started
selling insurance and now I'm 44 21
years and we went through the experience
of everybody was single and how they
would bring a different girlfriend or
boyfriend so you never know who was
serious then we went through the
experience of people getting engaged oh
my God engagement party all this stuff
which is kind of cool 28 years old then
you went through you know marriage oh my
God the guy's getting married let's go
to his wedding let's go to a wedding and
you know I threw a few divorces as well
some didn't work out and you have to
kind of go second try to return try then
people had kids and you want to
celebrate and say oh it's awesome you're
having kids it's great congratulations
to you then the second kid then a third
kid then you go into those parties and
then when your age is 44 parents start
dying that's kind of what we're going
through right now and it's hard uh one
of our guys's mother passed away
yesterday another one of our guys who's
there from both of them there you know
one of them was their day when the other
guy came in a year and a half after
started company
his mom passed away two weeks ago and
you had these conversations and this is
just happening more and more and more
because age is now in the force and when
you go into fives other experience is
going to happen we're going to go to
kids graduations and all this stuff six
you can have health issues someone had a
heart attack that could happen in your
50s stroke all this other stuff life is
going to happen and it's going to happen
to all of us whether it's a loss of a
loved one it's a bankruptcy it's a loss
of a job you lose a business you go
through challenging times you're going
through emotional times it doesn't
matter it's going to happen none of us
are free from it not Rob not you not Tom
not Barry not I not you but somehow some
way leaders figure out a way to go
through it
whether They Mourn privately and they do
with people they trust and they feel
safe with whether they go through it
amongst a church or somebody that they
feel comfortable to go talk about it
with uh but you're gonna go through it
however there's a reason why we follow
leaders because they know how to handle
tough times better than others so my
challenge to everybody listen to this
instead of being overwhelmed this is
real we're not faking it we're not
acting like this isn't real oh just go
read a positive thinking book It's gotta
be all right no it could be pretty ugly
the next six 12 months but if you choose
to lead it's times like this where you
create a reputation where people call
you a leader they don't call your leader
during Good Times They Call You leaders
on how you handle bad times and this is
the season so we just send a text at the
beginning of the podcast
and it went to people that were part of
the podcast okay for the second life
that's coming up at our studio the last
one we did was a hit we had a blast I'll
see if it ever coming in well I can tell
you in the first nine minutes the VIP
tickets sold out instantly I think
there's only 40 tickets left because the
people that got the text messages they
were able to go do it first now it's
being announced to everybody our second
live that we're gonna have will be a
different schedule we're gonna do it
from seven to nine you'll come at six
o'clock there's going to be different
things that you'll do and then from
seven to nine we'll do the podcast nine
to nine thirty we'll do private q a then
we'll do pictures mingling and then
we'll go into the Cigar Lounge have
conversation some of the best
conversations I had was in a cigar
lounge we sat down a lot of valuetainers
were asking questions hey what about
this and what about that and we had a
chance to network with everybody uh we
are currently scheduled for the sixth to
have uh Dave Rubin will be with us and
it is the weekend of UFC 287 or 283 one
of them so there's gonna be a lot of
other people in town can't tell you who
else is going to be there but we got
some friends we're talking about that
could be there at the event as well so
if you haven't yet bought your tickets
Robert let's make sure we put in the
description in the chat uh and in the
comment section so you can get your
ticket it will sell out ASAP I am
looking forward to seeing many of you on
April 6th with us at our new studio
having said that Barry thanks for coming
out it was phenomenal very good Insight
it's a privilege to be here I I love
everything you do
follow every single one of your posts
it's like I don't know how you find this
amazing stuff anybody who's not
following you is crazy but uh but thank
you for all you do I appreciate it
thanks for having me on yeah this was
great believe me this was great you guys
you guys are awesome Barry it's been a
while and just by the way I think we had
15 16 000 live with us today if this is
your first time watching pbd podcast we
do this weekly yeah three times a week
join us subscribe be a part of what
we're doing a lot of content on
Instagram if you I am Barry Habib just
if you want to follow it but a lot of a
lot of this short content on about these
types of topics so what's the best place
to look you up as a Twitter or Instagram
Instagram I am Barry Habib I am Barry
Habib that's it
h-a-b-i-ib yeah Barry Habib I am Barry
Habib on Instagram take care everybody
bye bye bye bye